löcher meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
der minecraft commands heute hier am
freitag trotz dessen der tatsache dass
einige andere youtuber serien übernehmen
beziehungsweise commands wahrnehmen bzw
video ideen übernehmen
et cetera pp was sich angedeutet habe
ist ja auch egal habe ich mir gedacht
dass ich eine neue folge heute ich am
freitag hochladen weil ihr mir wieder
unglaublich glück mal zugesendet habt
und ich würde sagen wir familie kann mit
dem ersten command ich habe hier schon
einen befehls noch in einen hebel die
setz dich mal hier beide zu normal hin
gebe diesen command ein damit zu
gesendet wurde von will wright engineer
der hut wo liegen ihm eine serie ist ein
engländer amerikaner keine ahnung
wollten auf jeden fall zugesendet in
meinen commands formular und wenn ich
jetzt auch fertig drücke wds hatten
kleinen moment geruckelt und jetzt
drücke ich gleich mal eben diesen hebel
hier und dann seht ihr schon wird das
hier erschaffen ist sogar eingeblendet
unten drin und zwar ist das eine mining
turtle in minecraft vanilla also wir
sehen dass ihr tier und schwedt bitte
link ringe und dann sehen wir jetzt auf
dieser seite hier so ein paar knöpfchen
hiermit können wir die maschine gleich
wieder zerstören
dann haben wir hier die turtle zu
bekommen und hier um die wieder zu
zerstören da drücke ich mal die beiden
sachen und zwar bekomme ich jetzt diese
spox was wir schon aus anderen sachen
kennen das war beispielsweise auch bei
dem command sowohl beispielsweise ganz
viele waffen auf einmal kommen und so
weiter und so fort
also ich drücke jetzt beispielsweise mit
diesem spot einfach mal hier auf dem
boden und dann seht ihr schon eine
karibik gebildet das war jetzt ein
bisschen blöd ich hier oben zu
platzieren weil die jetzt quasi hier nur
über geld
das war extrem blöd aber wir haben jetzt
hier beispielsweise diese kisten das
hier ist übrigens der zweite command
gleich noch eine kiste zu machen
ist aber auch egal jedenfalls werden
hier dann so sachen eingesammelt hatte c
beispielsweise nur drei weizenkörner
drin das war es jetzt
man müsste die halt einfach mal so ein
bisschen im untergrund platz ihr nicht
gehen dafür mal ein bisschen nach und
beispielsweise und setzten hier einfach
mal hin
dann wird es schon werden hier direkt
die kissling gestellt und jetzt seht ihr
auch schon die kisten füllen sich hier
beispielsweise mit granit was haben wir
denn hier noch so jetzt ist hier auch
noch stand und granit drin und ist auf
jeden fall recht geil also quasi eine
mining turtle in minecraft vanilla und
kann es beispielsweise 4
das ist ein sehr komisches und dann ist
auch beispielsweise hier detroit query
klicken dann wird die quasi zerstört
also wenn ich hier eine hinsetzen ich
drücke dann die story schon lief weg und
das ist quasi auch schon command nummer
eins ganz simpel es ist einfach eine
mining turtle in vanilla dass mir zu
gesendet wurde von dem command
hersteller ihr himself quasi ist ein
ganz simpler command allerdings sehr
sehr geil gemacht und zwar wenn ich
beispielsweise immer eine curry hinsetzt
und ich gehe mal in den game ort drei da
kann man ja sehen ob es solche dinge
dann immer bestehen die entities blabla
und das nämlich einrüstung ständer und
ein kleines männchen was einfach sofort
mit einer spitzhacke sieht schon ganz
witzig aus baut sich jetzt hier den weg
vor und ich weiß zwar nicht was das für
ein komischer sound war der da
abgespielt wurde aber irgendwie war da
mein ding ich war vorhin sondern
nervtötender sound keine ahnung woher
kam aber das ist auf jeden fall meinen
turtle in minecraft vanilla mehr oder
weniger echt jetzt nochmal den game und
1 damit das geht hier hinten bei den
kisten die ec kreiert wurden seht ihr
schon da sind hier beispielsweise sind
jetzt schon ein paar sachen drin
die damit quasi für euch dann ärzte et
cetera ein das war 0 1 und wir machen
der mit nummer zwei und nummer zwei ist
eine sache die ich euch ja schon mal
vorgestellt hatte vor einem jahr oder
irgendwie so okay so lang ist nicht
halbes jahr keine ahnung wurde mir jetzt
noch mal zugesendet von juni und zwar
eine dreifach kiste so freuen wir machen
das ganze jetzt hier vorne einfach noch
mal und zwar gewisser zuerst diesen
kommentar ein landwirt ich hier eine
kiste platziert dann gebe ich jetzt
beispielsweise den command hier ein wo
11 ist also dabei der anderen das sind
die koordinaten einfach meine xyz
koordinate die plus eins und die auch
noch +1 dann haben wir da noch eine
kiste und jetzt gebe ich nämlich diesen
kommentaren und jetzt habe ich es sieht
man jetzt habe ich gerade gar nicht an
die sieht man nicht deswegen wurde ich
angezeigt weiß ich ja hier hier ist die
eigentlich ist die dritte kiste und dann
habe ich quasi hier so eine dreifach
kiste die quasi sogar aussieht wie eine
zweifach ist werden dass er damals so
ist die dann irgendwie daneben standen
total crazy das auch so sieht es
allerdings so aus
natürlich der blog ist jetzt anvisiert
und sie dort wie luft quasi oder
unsichtbar aber es ist halt eine
dreifach ist also ich kann die so öffnen
und ihr könnt das ja quasi einfach so
ein baum in einem haus von dieser seite
irgendwie so mit dem commander da weiß
ich dass es von dieser seite ist dann
könnt ihr die öffnende dann habt ihr
alles noch so einen zusatz slot dass sie
zwar ein bisschen crazy außerdem texture
pack und es sieht auch nicht nur einem
tag das sieht nicht nur schick sondern
es liegt auch in minecraft default
expect ein bisschen komisch aus aber ihr
habt auf jeden fall eine dreifach kiste
habe ich euch ja schon mal in den pakt
irgendwann mal ganz damals gezeigt
allerdings wie gesagt diese commands
folge kommen auch teilweise effekt an
die ich damals bei tests gezeigt habt
weil es halt auch command sind und weil
auch vollkommen egal woher nimmt ich
möchte euch die einfach nur vorstellen
und
kommen wir zur hand nummer drei habe ich
hatte ihr gesagt anstatt commands so
freunde wie schon in der folge von vor
zwei wochen oder so gesagt hat und
angekündigt hatte dass ich euch die
möbel vorstelle die ich versprochen
hatte sage ich euch jetzt hier einfach
mal den command ich geb den hier ein die
lage natürlich ganz kurz ich mache das
hier drücke den schalter und jetzt kommt
hier eine kleine maschine der command
ist wieder von ea mannschaft ort am main
kräftig sollen nicht ganz genau wie man
einen namen ausspricht
ich denke mal wird das video hier sehen
der hat ja letztens auch irgendwann mal
kommentiert du machst auf jeden fall
richtig geile commands grüße gehen raus
an dich schaut auf jeden fall mal vorbei
wer den bock auf commands abwehr ihm und
dann haben wir halt hier diese maschine
einmal destroy maschinen und geld items
und jetzt bekomme ich hier diese items
das hab ich euch ja vor zwei folgen oder
so hatte ich euch ja schon mal gesagt ja
wenn ihr bock auf möbel habt dann hört
euch auf jeden fall die nächste folge an
dann kam ein anderer youtuber und hat
das auch vorgestellt fand ich ein
bisschen doof aber naja kann man nichts
machen weil ja auch kein held hier sein
kann ja jeder machen was er will kann
ich jetzt noch ein bisschen traurig aber
wir kommen zurück zum command den ich
euch natürlich nur vorstellen möchte und
hier nicht irgendwie was weiß ich was
machen möchte
also wir haben 515 spawn ex wir haben
einen char also einen stuhl einen tisch
einen großen tisch ein bücherregal mehr
oder weniger und noch einen fernseher
schicken
ich kann man hier eben den tschechen
stellen sehen schon das ist ein ganz
normaler chair der wahrscheinlich so
gemacht wurde dass das irgendwie ja die
die irgendein rüstung ständer oder
irgendein ob der darunter ist oder ein
pferd oder ein schwein oder irgendwie
sowas die reiten ja manchmal solche
items weil man kann sich hier natürlich
auch drauf setzen sollte jetzt seht ihr
dass ich sitze ich auf dem stuhl drauf
also wir haben jetzt genug
als ich denke wird sich zeigen möchte
man kann sich hier draufsetzen falsch
ausgedrückt ich will hier runter weil
das achte können mit dem game 3 kommt es
jetzt im schweine sondern fährt es ist
ein pferd und es hat quasi den sattel
auf und das sind halt dann quasi so
einfach diese fallschirm ist ganz geil
gemacht die items da zusammengebastelt
genau das ist halt auch bei der bei der
mine etwa gewesen also das ist der stuhl
dann haben wir noch einen zweifel haben
das sind so zwei kleine tische dann
haben wir noch einen großen tisch der
allerdings ein wenig verpacktes und zwar
sind das hier eigentlich so glasscheiben
die man dann quasi einfach so hin
platzieren
die hat einfach hin platziert hat
allerdings ist das ganze halt hier
irgendwie zusammen gehalten und bei mir
funktioniert das ganze nicht so das war
auch schon als ich das getestet hatte
vor drei wochen oder vor zwei wochen
keine ahnung genau wie ich das gesagt
hat in der folge war das auch schon so
dass der glas tisch nicht so richtig
funktioniert hatte keine ahnung
jetzt können aber eben schauen hier die
tische sind auch rüstungs ständer mäßig
gemacht sieht auch sehr sehr leicht aus
und das sind so knochen die da einfach
ausdrucken zusteht nicht so ganz
aber ich bin auch nicht hier um das zu
verstehen sondern nur uns vorzustellen
meine damen und herren haben wir das
power of books das müsste eigentlich
funktionieren ja genau das plant ein
bücherregal sondern einfach nur so ein
paar bücher lieber nach hinlegen kann
könnt ihr auf jeden block drauflegen
wird sogar ganz geil aus weil das so
quasi obendrauf legt das heißt wenn
jetzt beispielsweise rein theoretisch
sogar ein bücherregal rom stehen haben
wir das da rein theoretisch so drauf
legen dass wir dann mehr oder weniger so
wirklich ein wenig führt konturen im
raum sorgen indem wir diese bücher
einfach auf das bücher ding drauflegen
so ich ganz neue unterkunft mit rot hoch
und die letzte sache ist ein tv sehr
sehr gerne gemacht finde ich sehr sehr
cool der tv sieht echt aussehen
fernseher finde ich sehr sehr geil sieht
vor allem also ist halt so mit wolle
gemacht denke ich mal sieht vor allem
auch oder liegt das jetzt gerade daran
dass es einfach von der sonne ist ja auf
beiden seiten wolle ja ich meine jetzt
doch auf beiden seiten voll ich dachte
sogar der wehr auf der einen seite nicht
wolle sondern so ein etwas ganz anderes
material seht ihr auch wieder ist mit
sind das eigentlich rüstung ständer
ich meine dass entrüstung stände hier
überall mit denen das kreiert wurde also
hier auf jeden fall das sieht man ja
hier dann wahrscheinlich auch also es
wurde alles mit rüstung steinerne
gemacht aus da hier das mit dem pferd
sehr sehr geil finde ich eine gute
arbeit geleistet finde ich sehr sehr
cool diese
command habe ich mir schon öfters mal
gewünscht dass mehr möbel modellierungs
möglichkeiten in minecraft kann man sich
an den kräften denen vorgestellt und so
weiter und so fort
sehr sehr geiles gesellschaftlich segert
wir sind bei der folge schon wieder voll
über derzeit also es gibt ja kein
zeitlimit mehr oder weniger bei youtube
aber ich muss weg deswegen kann ich euch
die anderen beiden command sei da nicht
mehr vorstellen die ich jetzt hier in
meiner datei noch aufgeschrieben habe
ich würde einfach sagen dass die kommen
in der nächsten folge drankommen die ich
jedoch stehen noch sind auf jeden fall
auch wieder recht geile commands nicht
auch so auch so ja auch so deko sachen
halt wieder hinzufügen nicht dass jetzt
mehr anlass das find ich sag mal lieber
nicht mehr wartet einfach die nächste
folge ab jedenfalls würde ich mich
freuen wenn du das video positiv
bewertet geht freue ich durchs leben
freunde heute ist ein wundervoller tag
heute ist zwar eine sonnenfinsternis
aber naja ich wünsche ich da sagen ja
immer alle hahaha luca du kannst ja
garnicht kollege spielen hier ich kann
das nicht auf
kapo ybu